الاولي تم نقلها بشكل مباشر الى القوات
المقاتله في قطاع غزه ممثلو جيش الدفاع
عرضوا هذه على العائلات لالون وتامر
ليرحمهم الله جيش الدفاع جميعا يركن
راسه نحن سنواصل التحقيق في هذا الحدث حتى
النهايه ونحن في قمه
حرب و ولجنا اوضاع صعبه
ومعقده وايضا هناك بعض الامور الصعبه لم
نراها من قبل وخلال نهايه الاسبوع قامت
قوات جيش الدفاع وجهاز الاستخبارات في عمل
في مستشفى العدوان في وفي منطقه جباليا
اقت تقلنا اكثر من 80 من المخربين وحققنا
معهم في المستشفى الذين اوصلو الى اسلحه
موجوده في اقسام الاطفال واقسام اخرى في
المستشفى بالاضافه لذلك كشفنا بنى ارهابيه
وايضا كانت هناك الكثير من الاسلحه التي
تم نقلها الى قطاع غزه في الشمال طائرات
جيش الدفاع هاجمت عده اهداف لحزب الله في
جنوب لبنان وبينها مباني عسكريه ومناطق
اطلاق وبنى ارهابيه وايضا ذلك ردا على
اطلاق المسيرات التي دخلت من الحدود
اللبنانيه احدى المسيرات تم اسقاطه والاخر
اصاب
مقاتل جيش الدفاع قتل احد الجنود وهو
ازاريا يبلغ من العمر 53 عا لا يرحمه الله
القوات في القياده الشماليه موجوده على
استعداد تام سنواصل قتل كل مخرب يحاول ان
يطلق النار الى منطقتنا او الدخول الى
منطقتنا وسنواصل الهجوم بقوه كبيره اهداف
حزب الله ردا على كل عمليه عمليه اعتدائه
ضد دوله اسرائيل تقينا اليوم تذكيرا
للتعاون بيننا بين شركائنا في في
المنطقه السطول الخامس الذي يعمل في البحر
الاحمر تم اسقط 14
مسيره التي تم اطلاقها من المناطق تحت
سيطره الحوثيين في اليمن من منطقه الحديده
التي كانت في طريقها الى دوله اسرائيل تم
اسقاطها في البحر الاحمر وهذا التعاون
الكبير وايضا على المنطقه الم
والسلاح البحريه الاسرائيليه وهذه الصوره
المشتركه وهذا اثبات انه يتم اسقاط
الاسقاط ليس المره الاولى للمسيرات
المتجهه لدوله اسرائيل وهذا ايضا لزياره
قائده المنطقه المركزيه الجنرال برا الذي
ظهر في نهايه الاسبوع وقان التقى مع رئيس
الاركان وقام هناك تقييما ومحادثات ايضا
كانت هناك استعدادات للدفاع ضد التهديدات
من قبلان وايضا تم مناقشه هذه المواضيع
ومواص القتال
اسئله عندما لدينا اكثر من 100 من
المخطوفين
ايضا
اي وايضا هل تتحدثون عن اشاره مكتوبه
انقذو في المنطقه التي كانت المخوف
المخطوفين
وهذا حادث يتكرر كل هذا الحادث هو
حادث
درامي التي قتل فيه ثلاثه اسرائيليين وكما
قال رئيس الاركان اليوم
سنعمل كل قاموا بكل ما يمكن القيام به
نزعوا ملابسهم وايضا رفعوا علم ابيض ونحن
نفحص هل هناك في المبنى على بعد 200 متر
كما نفحص هذا هذا ما في المبنى يمكن ان
يكون اشاروا الى اشارات انقذونا وايضا حيث
كان المخطوفين
الثلاثه وثلاثه
اسرائيليين وسامر والون وتام اللي ارحمهم
الله عملوا كل ما يمكن القيام به من اجل
انقاذهم وكانت هناك نتيجه صعبه يجب ان
نفهم قواتنا الموجوده في الميدان يحاربون
المخربين وبعد هذا الحدث كان هناك مواجهات
مع المخربين نس المنطقه الذين يلبسون
ملابس مدنيه مخربون يعدون العبوات الناسفه
ويقومون بالاعتداءات فيحاولون القيام
بامور يسحبون فيها الجنود من اجل قتلهم
وهذه حرب تحت ضغط كبير موجودون نحن فيه
وحتى هذا الامر الجنود في المنطقه كانوا
في وضع في كانوا هناك جنود في مبنى او في
نفق مربوطين لم نرى مثل هذه امور الذين
هنا هم يتجهون نحونا ويجب ان نقول اننا
موجودون في قياده قياده نيتسان الون على
مدار الساعه هناك جمع للمعلومات
الاستخباريه من الميدان وايضا كيف يجب ان
متى نكون حاضرين واين نكون حاضرين وهذا لم
يكن لدينا معلومات عنه في هذه المنطقه
المحدده وايضا هذه الامور يجب ان نكون
هناك عمليات خاصه من اجل ان ننقذ
المخطوفين هناك الحدث يجب ان نتعلم به
ولذلك نعمل على مدى 24 ساعه للتحقيق في
هذا الحادث من رئيس الاركان وحتى المحارب
الاخير في الميدان نحن ندرس هذا هذه
الحادثه وايضا في نهايه الامر يجب ان نؤكد
على الجنود المحاربين في الميدان على
التاكيدات لان نحصل على ظروف وفرص اخرى من
اجل اعاده المخطوفين الى الى
احياء الى الوطن ما نجح من اجل ان نرى
هؤلاء المخطوفين
يهربون ايضا لما تركوهم من قتل المخربين
في ال هي العمليه البريه وليس الا ويجب ان
نفهم ان يكون هناك فرص اخرى من هذه الفرص
ويجب ان نكون حذرين جدا ومن اجل ان نعطي
نتيجه مختلفه شفير القنا 11 اريد ان احدد
لم يكن هناك استخبارات
حول امكانيه وج ه المخو في هذه المنطقه
التي كان هناك فيها قتال الشجاعيه عليه لم
يكن لم تكونوا مستعدين لهذه
الامكانيه علينا ان نؤكد ان لدينا هناك
استخبارات في مناطق معينه هناك استخبارات
عن
وجود مخطوفين هربوا لم يكن لدينا مثل هذه
المعلومات كانت لدينا معلومات بشكل عام في
المنطقه بالنسبه لكافه القوات هي مستعده
وكنا وكنا مستعدين لان نكون من هو موجود
مخطوف في منطقه تحت الارض وفي النفق هذا
هو الذي هذا هو الوضع الذي استعدنا له
ونحن نبلغ كافه القوات حول امكانيه من هذه
الامكانيات وعليه
النتيجه هي نتيجه دراميه
ونعمل كل شيء ومن اجل المره القادمه ان
نعيد الى الوطن مخطوفين احياء وهذا كل ما
يفكر به جندي جيش الدفاع عندما يدخل الى
قطاع غزه ان ننقذ او ان نخلص المخطوفين
هذه هذا ما يريد ان يقوم به الجنود ايضا
نحن موجودون في وضعيه مركبه وظروف ضغط
كبيره لا يمكن ان يقف احد فيها عندما
يطلقون النار ايضا موجودون مخربون
بالملابس المدنيه وفي مواجه
نهايه الامر الامر المهم جدا هو ناخذ
العبر ان نبلغ كافه القوات وان نواصل
القتال حتى ان نحقق النتائج وان نحقق
اهداف الحرب تفكيك حماس واعاده المخطوفين
الى الوطن